Her low freak bitches.
How are you sir?
I'm very good,
Joe.
It's good to meet you,
man.
Great to meet you.
And thank you very much for doing this.
I've learned more about coyotes over the last couple of months reading your book
and listening to your podcast with my good friend Steve Rinella,
which was amazing.
Oh,
what a crazy animal that is.
You know,
I have coyotes all around my neighborhood and uh,
it became a very,
um,
it's very close to me when I saw one of my chickens get captured by a coyote and
I watched him hop the fence where the chicken in his mouth,
boy,
God damn,
these mother fuckers and just all around us.
Especially,
I live in a fairly rural area around here.
I'm about a 40 minutes outside of La,
so it's,
you know,
the nights are quiet and you hear him screaming in the night and I didn't know
much about them until I started reading your book,
man.
Yeah,
they're amazing animal.
I mean,
I think,
uh,
there's not really another mammal aside from us that has a biography lock these
animals do.
And that's kind of one of the reasons I got fascinated with them.
Uh,
they were doing the same thing around me when I was a kid growing up in
Louisiana.
I mean,
and that's sort of the beginning of my,
uh,
my getting captivated by these little small wolves because they were suddenly
showing up in the bayous and swamps of Louisiana when I was 12,
13,
14 years old.
And as far as I knew this was an animal that was supposed to be in the deserts
of the West.
And so that seemed to be something that,
you know,
commanded a one's attention,
that this critter is,
is appearing in places where you would never expect it.
Uh,
and now of course everybody in the country is dealing with them.
That is so fascinating that in our lifetime they have spread from the American
southwest to every single state and literally every single city in the country.
Yeah,
it's true.
And I just got a,
somebody sent me this yesterday that somewhere in Georgia they have some sort of
a bounty on these wolves.
Coyotes.
That's what one thing a lot of people don't realize that a coyote is a wolf.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a separate species from gray wolves in red wolves,
but it's out of the North American wolf line.
Uh,
I mean Kyries are distinctively North American animals.
They come out of Canaan evolution that began here 5.3 million years ago.
So,
um,
yeah,
they're,
they're small wolves.
And I send you this Jamie.
No,
you found it beautiful.
This is the Georgia coyote challenge.
Apparently they're offering some sort of bounty for each coyote killed.
Now what's fascinating about this,
and one of the things that I learned from your book is that when a coyote yells,
when they're doing their call in the night,
they're essentially making roll call.
And when one of them doesn't respond,
the female generates more pups.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's one of the,
you know,
one of the many things that's probably happening when they're,
when they're howling.
I mean they are taking a census basically of of coyote populations in the area.
And the result of,
of that census can very well be,
it produces some sort of a chemical or a metabolic change in the females,
the breeding females,
the Alpha ones,
and they end up oftentimes having larger litters of pups,
which is why something like this,
you know,
I was just in South Carolina two weeks ago and there was a lot of conversation
about this,
this Georgia bounty,
because in South Carolina,
it's another place where coyotes are,
are fairly new.
I've only been there in the last 20 or 25 years.
They were arguing that,
you know,
and they had some pretty good science that coyotes are taking,
in some areas,
as many as 60% of the white tail deer fawns.
And so the hunters are screaming a long and loud about this because it means
it's getting harder to take a whitetail.
So South Carolina hasn't moved to the step that Georgia has of trying to impose
some kind of bounty and encourage people to go out and shoot these animals,
uh,
to take them in any way they can,
but mostly shoot them.
Uh,
but you know,
I think these states in the south and in the east have a lot to learn by the
western or from the Western experience because the truth is we've been trying to
eradicate,
and I mean totally exterminate coyotes in the American west.
Uh,
we spent the years from about 1915 through about 1972 and an all out war
attempting to exterminate them.
And the only result of that,
uh,
as a result of their particular kinds of adaptations in their evolution in North
America,
uh,
is that we spread them across the entire country.
We not only spread them across the entire country,
I mean,
they're in every state.
They colonized their 49th state,
Delaware in 2010.
So the only state,
they're not in his Hawaii just because they have a stowed away and made it
across the Pacific yet.
And,
uh,
you know,
I mean,
if they do,
you can imagine that those endangered Naynay's on the big island are totally
done for,
but they are not only in every single state in the union except for a why,
but they are 7,000 miles now north and south and North America from above the
Arctic Circle,
all the way down to Central America and beginning to colonize into South
America.
So the attempts to exterminate them,
I mean,
and I can explain how this,
why this happens has to do with their evolution and the particular deputations
they have,
but the attempts to exterminate them or even to try to control their numbers
almost always produces exactly the opposite effect.
So Georgia is going to end up with more coyotes than they've ever had before in
their efforts to try to suppress their population.
Isn't that fascinating?
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.